it is great to have back on the program
Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon Morning Show who is uh up to some
very important work I will say which
we're going to talk about Ben always
great having you on David it's a
pleasure thanks so much for having me so
Christian nationalism you know sometimes
there's this shorthand when when people
say well what what does Christian
nationalism mean and you can imagine a
spectrum where on one side you have
separation of church and state where
whatever one's religion is it has
nothing to do with civil government the
shorthand that sometimes is used is will
the opposite side of that spectrum is
for example Marjorie Taylor green who
says no her Christianity should be
exactly what dictates and determines how
civil government should operate is that
the right way to think about this
movement absolutely I think Marjorie
Taylor green inadvertently gave us the
perfect lens to which we need to
understand this threat that's coming
from I would like to say my colleagues
uh in the Christian faith but there is a
sect of Christians who believe that
their specific brand of Christianity
should be what dominates the entirety of
society and clearly that's a threat not
only to those who choose not to believe
or have any other belief but it's a
threat to those of us Christians who
simply do not believe in these
sectarianism and the tribalism of
Christian nationalism has something
materially changed since like I remember
in the early days of my show there would
be the televangelists and you would see
a little bit of an inkling of this
Christian nationalism but you you didn't
see as much over you know you can't be
Christian and vote for a Democrat uh
preaching politics from the pulpit was
it there but less overt or has something
actually changed there's it well it
certainly has been there the entire time
there's always been a faction of the
Christian religion that believes in
dominionism and dominionism is quite
literally the best way to describe it
they believe that they have the
authority to dominate Society some of
them even go as far as believing that
they should bring do what they can to
um expedite the apocalypse so to speak
that trend has always been there but
what kind of control they had inside of
the Republican party that was a
different question and we saw back when
I got started even I got started around
the Jeremiah right time there was this
belief in the Republican party that they
could capitalize on the Evangelical vote
without having to subscribe or bow down
to the more zealotrous form of
Evangelical white evangelicalism to be
specific and we see now that after years
and years and years of getting the votes
of these particular types of
evangelicals that group has taken
control of the Republican Party can you
mention white evangelicals can you talk
a little bit about the the kind of
racial breakdown of these movements
because we've known for a while that uh
for example in the Prop 8 era in
California there certainly are
conservative religious values in black
churches that's right but is there a
difference in terms of the political
application as it comes to Christian
nationalism between some of these
different groups of churches absolutely
I think back a hearken back to the
statement from Malcolm X that 11 o'clock
on Sunday mornings is the most
segregated time in America and that's
because there's a fundamental difference
between black Christianity and white
evangelicalism not so much in terms of
our belief in Jesus that fundamental
belief in Jesus is the same but you have
to take into context when black people
were praying for deliverance from Jim
Crow praying for deliverance from
slavery we were literally asking God to
Deliver Us from White evangelicals who
would Lynch us on Sunday morning and
then go to Sunday school so the
difference really lies in the value of
human life in terms of black people the
willingness to
decapitate the entire message of Justice
you think about the Thomas Jefferson
Bible where they completely erased any
semblance of justice and the the
narratives of setting free the captive
they took that out of the Bible and gave
that to the slave save the enslaved
person because they fundamentally
understood that that messaging would
Galvanize a black liberation movement
which inevitably happened anyway
you know I got a call I think it was
last week or the week before from a
self-described white Progressive
Christian and this guy described his
views about a number of different issues
and they were pretty conservative views
but what made him a progressive was he
doesn't think any of those opinions
should have any bearing on what
government does so that's an interesting
thing because sometimes it's not about I
mean I don't know you you tell me when
we talk about the progressive Christian
Movement is it still conservative but it
says that that conservatism should be
completely separate from how folks vote
or what is it exactly yeah there's a
wide range of beliefs in Christianity I
mean in terms of like so if we just talk
about social issues there's a large
group of Christians who fundamentally
and they use theology to support lgbtq
rights so there is a broad range but
even in the Progressive circles that
hold on to conservative beliefs there's
like you mentioned the black community
is extremely conservative derivative on
a lot of issues but where they draw we
draw the line fundamentally is we don't
believe that our beliefs should be used
to discriminate against anyone else
whereas Marjorie Taylor green not only
believes that those beliefs should be
used to discriminate they believe that
it should be the fundamental tool by
which we organize Society they don't
believe in democracy anymore they
fundamentally believe in a Theocratic
fascist State and when we talk about the
particular theology it is a white
supremacist Christian nationalist
theology
hey when it comes to like the future of
the of Christianity in the context of
Christian nationalism I think I've seen
you either say or I read in some of the
info you sent me that you see Christian
nationalism as a threat to Christians
and Christianity as as you describe
yourself as a part of that movement can
you explain that oh absolutely uh in the
clip that's going viral now there's a uh
there's a particular white Evangelical
Pastor who was disgusted with the fact
that black people call ourselves
Christian
um and the reason for that disgust is
because he hated the fact that we fight
for justice we fight for Liberation we
fight for democracy we fight for things
that he feels is anathema to his
particular belief so there's a clear
divide in not only a divide but we are
not safe you have to understand and
anyone I mean I'm sure everyone can
contextualize it for history like this
type of nationalism this type of
Christian National journalism was the
justification for slavery it's now being
used as a justification for the bigotry
that we're seeing on every front so I
don't think black Christians are safe at
all I think we are going to be targeted
just as much as let's say the lgbtqia
community it's been interesting I guess
interesting I don't know there's
probably a different term for it but
it's been notable that Christian
nationalism has grown arguably as much
as at any time in the last couple of
decades during the presidency of a guy
who clearly was lying about his
religiosity like it's very very obvious
that Trump was never religious Trump was
never against abortion he kind of
contrived all these things in the run-up
to being the Republican nominee because
Democrats weren't going to going to make
him the the nominee
do you know what I mean I don't even
know how to ask the question like what
do you make of that because you would
think that you would not necessarily see
the growth of this movement when the
while they are simultaneously you know
uh pledging loyalty to a guy who is
obviously not religious yeah it's a it's
a really uh acute case of special
pleading
um they are willing to ignore everything
about Donald Trump because they felt
like he was the vessel that could
accomplish their agenda and in so many
ways he has right with all the
conservative appointments uh to the
Supreme Court and through the entire
Judiciary now with the rollback of Roe
versus Wade he has been a vessel to
accomplish their ends they did not care
whether or not he was more like Satan or
Jesus that was completely immaterial to
them
um and and I think we saw that happen in
that election and it's also
the last thing I'll say about it is that
these Christian nationalists you will
notice that they don't use the language
of Jesus they use the language of
Traditional Values and they get to
define those Traditional Values so I
would argue that it's not only the
result of them wanting to use Donald
Trump I believe they have the same level
of Faith as Donald Trump they're they're
in the realm of heresy based on their
own Bible they are looking at Donald
Trump as the second coming of Christ
there's a book out now that literally
calls Trump the second coming of Christ
I saw that it's a political opportunism
and they want power just as much as
anything else they they want political
power and economic power when folks talk
about how to fight against this movement
one of the first things that's mentioned
is hey you know
um if you're doing any kind of Politics
as a church you should lose your
tax-exempt status and there's this
feeling among some that the best way to
fight this is essentially a financial
fight demand investigations into the
non-profit status of some of these
churches and get them maybe I guess to
lose that status even though it very
rarely happens there's some hope that if
the IRS does uh kind of scale up
operations a little bit maybe this is
something that they would look at
although it doesn't really seem like a
priority do you think that that's an
important and viable way of fighting
this or do you think there are other
better ways well actually I don't think
it is not because I I disagree with the
tactic I do agree that if you are going
to use tax exempt dollars to accomplish
political ends you should lose your
501c3 status that's what the law says
sure however there's nothing that you
can give a Christian more than a victim
narrative if you can give them a
narrative but we're under attack by the
IRS their donations are going to go up
so I don't think it's an effective
strategy I think the more effective
strategy is to really extrapolate a
little bit higher because despite what
any Christian believes in their
individual Dogma if they are
if if they consider themselves to be a
person of good faith then they
understand that we're going to have to
coexist and I know that word has gotten
a little kind of uh kumbayas but the
fact of the matter is is that there is a
an alliance that has to be made between
people of good faith whatever they
believe so the IRS technique is PR I
don't know if they want to go after that
that's fine I think that gives
Christians nationalists more tools to
complain about so what are some of the
other ways that individuals whether they
are or aren't religious can get involved
in pushing back against this well one
you could just call them out on their
own frame right
um if I think a lot of times some of my
friends in the atheist or agnostic
Community they they want they would
rather
challenge the frame and dismiss the
possibility of God my suggestion is call
them out on their own BS right there's
nothing about Christian nationalism
that's remotely like Jesus based on the
Bible right there's nothing it's like
Gandhi said though he was a bit of a
racist he had this right he said that I
like your Christ just not your
Christians and there's no part of what
is being pushed by the Christian
nationalists that's even remotely kind
or just or reflects the image of Christ
and even if they don't like the image of
Christ I'm not talking about our allies
in The Atheist Community they're just
not good people I I think we can attack
them on their own frame because they
can't even stand up to their own their
own test last thing I want to talk about
we saw the Supreme Court overturn Roe v
Wade it was very obvious when that
happened like after your biggest Victory
you don't stop so so you know you're
gonna keep going now Lindsey Graham has
proposed an outright Federal ban on
abortion we don't know if gay marriage
might be coming next you know very far
down there's this idea of interracial
marriage although I don't think it's a
priority oh Ben did I just lose you
but we might have lost Ben
let's see if we can get Ben back
oh no
let's see if we can get Ben back what
what is this we were getting right to
the crescendo of the interview let's see
if we can get him back here
oh my
would be really a shame if I wasn't able
to get this question
foreign
something must have happened to his
internet tubes
oh boy
well listen we were coming to the end of
our time my question to Ben was going to
be
um do you expect
to see the churches
the right-wing churches get even more
extreme now that they sort of won in a
way on overturning Roe v Wade are they
just going to be pushing for more and
more extreme things but we'll have to
save it for next time Benjamin Dixon has
been joining us until we lost him host
of the Benjamin Dixon Morning Show we
will link to all of his stuff he's doing
great work fighting Christian
nationalism and we will take a quick
break and be back right after this